bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour la première fois un
sondage harris interactive donne marine
le pen à 48% des intentions de vote à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 en cas de
deuxième tour face à emmanuel macron 48%
c'est tout près de la victoire
d'ailleurs un autre sondage d lab nous
dit que près d'un français sur deux
pense désormais que marine le pen peut
l'emporter l'année prochaine mais bon ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on nous
dit que marine le pen est aux portes du
pouvoir c'est même un refrain connu que
l'on entend presque à chaque élection
alors qu'en est il exactement peut-elle
vraiment gagner cette fois n'est ce pas
un peu trop tôt pour faire ce genre de
pronostic
et si oui qu'est ce que cela signifie qu
est ce qui a changé en france pour que
marine le pen soit en mesure désormais
d'entrer à l'elysée pour en débattre
nous avons invité
erwan le nom vous êtes consultant
stratégie membre du cabinet de conseil
halterman membre du conseil scientifique
de la fondation pour l'innovation
politique fondapol vous enseigner le
droit et la macroéconomie à sciences po
vous êtes chroniqueur à l'opinion et aux
échos
est-ce que vous pensez que marine le pen
peut gagner en 2022 et si oui pourquoi
oui je pense que c'est possible pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que le
contexte cesse de se dégrader contexte
économique politique et social et
ensuite parce que la plupart des
candidats s'emploie à la place et comme
en réalité comme la leader de l'élection
à venir
tout ça fait que en art on entend 50 s
est lui favorable
maxime tandonnet vous avez été membre du
cabinet de nicolas sarkozy au ministère
de l'intérieur et ensuite à l'elysée
vous enseignez à paris xii et à
l'université de nice vous écrivez chaque
semaine dans le figaro vox vous est-ce
que vous pensez que marine le pen peut
l'emporter l'année prochaine et pourquoi
je pense que je peux l'emporter comme
tous les candidats on est dans une
démocratie
rien est exclu par avance cela dit je
pense que les flux l'élection
présidentielle n'est pas la
préoccupation principale des français
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils ont des tas
d'autres préoccupations dans une grille
sanitaires pouvant table ils pensent à
tout autre chose qu'à la présidentielle
je pense que les sondages lui
pratiquement rien dire à l'avancé on
voit que les pronostics des sondages
sont toujours démenti aux élections
présidentielles donc à mon avis c'est
roland ses chansons relativement sel
parce que demain les français choisiront
un candidat qui soit consensuel c'est un
personnage très client et cherchons la
compétence dans une situation de crise
sanitaire l'expérience et je suis pas
sûr que la candidate mme le pen soit la
mieux classée r j'étais garé françois
bousquet vous êtes rédacteur en chef de
la revue éléments dont le dernier numéro
est consacré à l'antispécisme avec une
interview de marine le pen vous diriger
la nouvelle librairie dont vous êtes
l'un des fondateurs une librairie et une
maison d'édition de droite qui se trouve
rue de médicis à paris vous êtes
l'auteur de courage manuel de guérilla
culturel et de
politique du coronavirus télé travail
famille patrie les deux sont édités par
la nouvelle librairie penser que marine
le pen peut l'emporter l'année prochaine
et pourquoi il faut rien s'interdire
surtout dans une émission comme la vôtre
pourquoi pas oui mitterrand et chirac
sont sont présentés deux fois avant
d'être élu une troisième fois ce sera
difficile et serré du reste dans le
sondage ne n'est pas donnée gagnante
mais il est faux de penser qu'il ya un
plafond de verre pour elle le sondage
après sondage ce plafond de verre est en
train de voler en éclats donc c'est une
hypothèse à envisager très sérieusement
me semble-t-il
alors il faut se souvient ce faux
souvenirs que l'on nous a dit déjà en
2017 que marine le pen pouvait
l'emporter
or à l'époque aucun sondage ne l'a donné
à plus de 40% des voix
donc si on disait s'acheter une forme de
chantage
c'était de dire si vous ne venez pas
voter si vous ne votez pas pour moi
marine le pen entrera l elysée alors
qu'on savait très bien que ce n'était
pas vrai est ce que est ce que
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il n'ya pas la
même tentation c'est à dire de crier au
loup au fond erwan le nom s'il ya
probablement la même tentation de crier
au loup et on voit bien que d'avoir
chacun des candidats a intérêt à se
retrouver un mari pense avoir intérêt à
retrouver face à marine le pen au second
tour dans l'espoir d'avoir un réflexe
républicain qu'il ferait à gagner
l'élection et on a vu que c'est un
stratagème politique a été utilisée
maintes fois dans les élections passées
se poser comme le principal recours pour
empêcher la victoire aux élections du
camp de marine le pen
donc effectivement ça il ya une part de
jeu mais ce qui me semble intéressant
sur les dernières années ça date pas de
ce mandat mais dd vraiment laid
l'intérêt depuis 2002 progressivement on
a installé marine le pen comme étant l'
alternative aux partis en place et c'est
d'autant plus vrai aujourd'hui qu'à part
le parti présidentiel
y'a pas de réellement deux parties qui
semble pouvoir assumer l'élection demain
donc l'alternative sans s'imposer de
plus en plus clairement et si les
électeurs sont trop fatigués de la
solution qu'ils ont aujourd'hui ça donne
ça ouvre une voie pour pour marine le
pen et rassemblement national maxime
tandonnet oui je suis assez d'accord ce
qui vient d'être dire sauf que j'ai lu
sur son dos sur les alternatives
possibles c'est vrai que les sondages
donnent toujours un binôme grande macro
le pen mais quand on regarde les
élections notamment les élections
municipales
on voit que la france la france profonde
était très fortement et en saveurs à la
fois de la droite qui obtient peu près
30 3% et même de la gauche qui est à un
niveau relativement élevé dans un
décalage entre les vraies élections les
sondages et à mon avis on a tort de se
focaliser uniquement sur les sondages
qui sont souvent biaisée cela dit je
rejoins tout à fait l'idée qu'il y a une
vraie volonté des politiques en tête des
politiques au pouvoir notamment de se
donner marine le pen comme comme
principal adversaire
alors on voit que la plupart des morts
avec le ministre de l'intérieur le débat
avec le ministre de la justice on voit
qu'il ya une volonté de toujours
remettre en avant marine le pen comme
l'opposant numéro un et j'ajoute qu'il
est aussi un jeu des médias qui est
malheureusement on n'est pas très n'est
pas toujours très clair à cet égard et
qu'on aime beaucoup faire du
sensationnel avec la victoire de marine
le pen le nombre de l'arctique sur le
duel est vital de le pen macro on les
compte plus ses partis et même excusez
moi mais si je vois le titre de votre
émission marine le pen peut-elle gagner
en 2010 point c'est très intéressant
mais ça montre bien quand même que cela
cette idée d'une victoire de marine le
pen sa fille sensationnelle ça fait bien
et puis
c'est vrai c'est beaucoup mis en avant
aussi bien dans les politiques que par
les médias donc je pense que le
phénomène de manipulation qui est très
forte sur l'idée d'un duel mc ren le pen
il qu'on n'y voit pas très clair
aujourd'hui sur ce qui va se passer en
réalité
messieurs et attitude parce que c'est la
question qu'on se pose donc c'est pas la
peine de tourner autour du pot
c'est vraiment la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui à la lumière de ces deux
sondages
à la fois 48% des français qui aurait
selon ce sondage harris interactive la
tension de voter pour elle face à
emmanuel macron 2022 mais aussi l'autre
leçon d'alger la bhl qui dit que près de
la moitié 48% aussi pense qu'elle peut
gagner
ça aussi ce serait nouveau françois
bousquet oui lorsque sur la question du
front républicain ou du front anti
fasciste bon il commença il commence à
s'épuiser ça fait depuis le 21 avril
2002 que cette comédie et jouer aux
français donc on se fait peur à bon
compte
les grands-parents des journalistes
n'ont pas arrêté hitler dans les
ardennes et mais ils vont arrêter le
front national dont à hénin-beaumont non
cette comédie a duré depuis assez
longtemps
je crois qu'il ya des raisons objectives
aujourd'hui à ce que marine le pen se
placent en tout cas en tête au premier
tour et dans une dynamique pour le
second tour il ya des raisons objectives
d'abord il ya le candidat macron en 2017
macron marine le pen était le meilleur
allié manif de fête du régime du système
et de son représentant emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui le meilleur allié de marie
le pen cemac ronces et les gilet jaune
c'est la politique macro depuis quelques
années peut-être que le système choisira
une autre alternative en 2017 en 2016
il y avait un sondage qui donnait qui a
donné marine le pen gagnante face à
françois hollande
françois hollande s'est mis en retrait
et peut-être que emmanuel macron se
mettra en retrait louhans venu si
sondage après sondage les français
plébiscitent un vote à vote et rennes à
votre marine le pen
il ya des raisons objectives sont sont
lourdes me semble-t-il
les idées du front national sont
majoritaires en france il ya une enquête
qui est menée chaque année depuis 30 ans
par kantar tns sofres le monde sur la
perception des idées du front national à
deux tiers c'est devenir un feuilleton
deux tiers des français plébiscitent en
tout cas dans les domaines régaliens
immigration sécurité frontières les
idées du front national mais aux deux
tiers il rejette le marine le pen et
hier jean-marie le pen autrement dit ils
plébiscitent le message et ils récusent
le médium donc on est très loin de mac
luhan là pour le coup le le message
n'est pas le médium donc tout l'effort
de marine le pen me semble-t-il c'est ce
à quoi elle s'adonne depuis un mois deux
mois qu'elle est rentrée en pré campagne
c'est d'offrir une image beaucoup plus
crédible en essayer de faire oublier le
débat calamiteux du deuxième tour en
2017 mais la résilience le lectorat est
si forte qu'il est déjà oubliée est me
semble-t-il on est on se dirige vers
deux blocs mais il n'y a que deux blocs
aujourd'hui en france il ya un bloc pour
parler comme jérôme sainte marie
ce qui est curieux aujourd'hui c'est que
les deux analyse me semble t'il les plus
fines qui seront produites sur le corps
électoral ces deux sondeurs pas des
intellos ces deux sondages
elles sont aux antipodes c'est la thèse
et l'antithèse mais peut-être faut-il en
faire une synthèse et cette synthèse
c'est peut-être le pen je pense à jérôme
sainte-marie donc sainte-marie dit qu'il
ya deux blocs en france un bloc élitaire
macro n'y en ait un bloc populiste
lepénistes et a contrario fort qui est
dit que la france cherchait belize se
balkanisé qui a pas de bloc pour ces
deux logiques assez assez différente
notre termes électoraux il ya
aujourd'hui à deux blocs 1 quelle est
l'alternative entre macron et le pen
dans l'espace politique se réduit ces
deux forces politiques aspirant le la
puissance gravitationnelle de ces deux
mouvements aspire autour de lui ses
marges donc les as l'air et le centre
droit pour macron le centre les
conservateurs pour marine le pen
mélenchon n'a plus du tout l'espace
politique en 2017 il y avait deux
offrent un peu plus distant c'est
important d'être bobby saab sera
vraiment égal en termes électoraux 20%
mélenchon ou 20% marine le pen mélenchon
a disparu des écrans radar il les prie
populiste ans aujourd'hui la réactiver
de la gauche de la gauche il et
indigéniste des colonials
post féministe courir tout ce qu'on
voudra mais il n'est plus populiste en
2017 mélenchon était populiste donc il y
avait deux offres pop laisse aujourd'hui
n'y a plus qu'une seule offre aux
populistes ce qui fait qu'ils risquent
d'avoir un très gros report de voix des
mélenchoniens en tout cas dans les
catégories populaires celles qui votent
françois ruffin et autres vers marine le
pen oui tout ça me fait dire que la
donne a changé et je crois pas qu'on
reproduire à deux fois les mêmes erreurs
moi je pense aux débats de mitterrand 74
qui est dévastateur en 80 il démolit des
maudits jeskar le l'homme du passé
démoli l'homme du passif entre les deux
il ya une opération de chirurgie
esthétique de chirurgie dentaire cercle
c'est le reflet le visage donc il ya de
la cosmétique et vous a pas échappé que
marine le pen ses dernières
interventions c'est les plus féminines
moins agressive - le pen
de plus marie dans quelque sorte donc
tout ça fait me fait dire et d'autres
ont d'autres choses encore que le
rapport de force a changé
réaction de roanne le noane je partage
une partie de ce qu'ils venaient de 10
sur la fin c'est bien sûr la façon dont
il ya un duel peut-être qui s'est
installée je pense qu'il faut le modéré
en tenant compte de l'abstention talent
je crois pas que par l'opinion française
aujourd'hui est ce ce blog soit
parfaitement avec une adhésion à cette
idée de deux blocs qui c'est qui qui
s'opposent en tout cas deux offrent une
alternative est unique
quand on voit le nombre d'abstentions de
personnes qui disent potentiellement
s'abstenir et en même temps le nombre de
personnes qui disent ne pas vouloir du
duel macro le pen c'est bien la preuve
que certes du ls et existe et est dans
le débat politique mais que les français
n'en veulent pas et que donc je suis
un espace en tout cas pour une offre
alternative est ce qu'elle a le temps
d'émerger est un autre sujet mais mais
je pense que le ce duel ne suscite pas
un enthousiasme fou des français et
c'est d'ailleurs en partie ce qui
pourrait d'ailleurs faire l'élection de
marine le pen c'est l'abstention
si beaucoup de gens ne vont pas voter ni
au premier ni au second tour et on voit
dans les derniers sondages aussi qu'une
partie des électeurs de gauche par
exemple pourrait s'abstenir au second
tour dans un duel macro le pen c'est
aussi un facteur qui est favorable
paradoxalement à la victoire du camp de
du rassemblement national maxime
tandonnet
oui moi je suis complètement d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit un instant
je pense que l'idée de le bloc contre
bloc blog populiste contre bloc
mondialiste en gros c'est extrêmement
caricaturale mais c'est une vraiment une
vision parisianiste de leçon d'art et de
son deux roues et du politiste ayant peu
forcément d'expérience de terrain
l'expérience des élections une dernière
élection municipale par part par contre
montre que le l'athlète de l'année
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus diverse que
ça je pense que l'immense majorité des
français 81% des français ne se
reconnaissent pas dans le duel marine le
pen y vient des sondages qui l'ont dit
l'ong qui l'ont qu'ils ont très bien
montré je crois que la grande majorité
des français elle veut sortir de la
crise sanitaire est loisible normalement
elle veut lutter contre la pauvreté
contre contre le chômage contre le mieux
maîtriser l'immigration elle veut lutter
contre l'insécurité
on n'est pas du tout dans l'ordre la
vienne ne t'entendra dans la vraie vie
on n'est pas dans l'idéologie
mondialiste contre le populiste crois
que c'est vraiment une vision à karim
très caricatural est très théorique je
pense que la grande majorité des
français n'est pas sur cette ligne
alors sa vision que vous qualifiez de
caricatural ou 2 août parisianiste au
fond c'est quand même la vision
de marine le pen françois bousquet mais
c'est peut-être aussi celle d'emmanuel
macron qui consiste à dire au fond il ya
deux blocs
oui enfin là évidemment ce moment on
n'est pas dans une séquence
présidentielle élection c'est dans un an
donc les français vont rentrer en
campagne on février mars en mars entre
en campagne
la campagne va durer trois mois il y
aura une telle dramaturgie pour la
campagne c'est le suffrage universel le
veut ça que c'est un moment de pensée
magique d'élections pendant trois mois
on pense que notre bulletin de vote
déposés dans l'isoloir dans l'urne le
pardon va changer la face du monde
donc on y croit tous ces hauts niveaux
vraiment on y croit tous on y croit
pendant trois mois évidemment dès le
lendemain c'est la gueule de bois des
lendemains c'est l'atterrissage
donc on n'en est pas là il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui les français ne pense
absolument pas ça n'intéresse que les
journalistes pour répondre à maxime tant
donné je remercie de dire que c'est une
vision parisianiste non je vis dans la
france périphérique mais pour autant
j'ai bien conscience que la france
périphérique les l'élection
présidentielle ne concerne pas encore
les gens ne concerne pas les français
et pour cause ils ont d'autres d'autres
problématiques vous l'avez dit
sanitaires économiques sociales mais il
n'empêche que dans un an et bien se
mettra en place le scénario de la
présidentielle
il rejoue à tous les coups le même
schéma cercueil à une mobilisation
c'est la mère des élections c'est par
définition c'est l'élection ou le
lectorat se déplace ou l'abstention est
la plus faible peut-être sur intel forte
au deuxième tour comme il a été dit dans
un premier temps quand les électeurs de
gauche ou de quads la gauche de la
gauche ne se décideront pas ne voudront
pas arbitré au fond comme mélenchon en
2017 voudront pas à arbitrer entre
marine le pen et
et emmanuel macron on en n'est pas là là
évidemment on pose des scénarios on joue
un jeu c'est un jeu fictif on joue à
l'élection en l'élection aura lieu dans
un an ça va de soi pour autant il me
semble que s'imaginer qu'il ya pas de
bloc en france c'est ne pas comprendre
ce qui s'est passé en angleterre c'est
ne pas comprendre ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis il ya une crispation de part
et d'autre on pourrait presque dire elle
qui a une montée aux extrêmes en tout
cas aux états unis aux états unis entre
lecteurs de weiden l'acteur de trump ils
n'ont plus rien à se dire
ils sont sur la logique amis et demi et
2 c'est en train d'arriver en europe
en france évidemment sans la dimension
caricaturale des américains marine le
pen dépasse trump tram c'est un autre
plan de spectacles dans une société qui
aime ça qui va faire le show
marine le pen n'est pas du tout dans ce
registre là mais il n'empêche le il ya
une crispation de part et d'autre et je
ne vois pas d espace politique alors
évidemment il ya des espaces politiques
dans toutes les élections et dans toutes
les élections intermédiaires ce sont les
élections intermédiaires c'est des
actions dans lesquelles le front
national aller plus fort taux
d'abstention
rappelez-vous l'élection des députés
elle verrait même un an dernier 17 à peu
près là les catégories populaires les
ouvriers en tout cas les plus bas
revenus à 80% s'abstiennent donc s'il ya
un défaut de conception si on s'en tient
aux intermédiaires
l'important c'est la mère des élections
je leur dis c'est la pensée magique
c'est de ce doux l'efficacité redoutable
inde où sa capacité à mobiliser la
nation dans son ensemble et à laisser
une marge très résiduel à l'abstention
peut être que ça changera en 2022 on
n'en est pas là mais je crois que ces
deux scénarios qui s'avance vers nous à
ce que ce sera macron other lip6 edouard
philippe évidemment la donne se renverse
je le redis le meilleur allié de mme
harel de bonnes aujourd'hui c'est macron
macron c'est l'homme qui a pendant un an
et demi
envoyez des tirs de lanceurs de défense
qui à bord y aider une population avec
une violence qu'on n'avait jamais vu
depuis la guerre d'algérie donc
s'imaginer que les français l'ont oublié
donc je crois pas qu'il l'oublié
maxime tendait alors je vous prie de
m'excuser je voulais pas je dirais pas
pour vous je ne parle pas de
parisianisme pour vous bien sûr et plus
généralement
je suis vraiment désolé de même je suis
désolé les amis de monsieur tnet taddei
je parlais du tyne par une plaine
peut-elle devenir 2022 c'était bon
c'était un exemple quoi c'était un crime
non non mais non mais je suis d'accord
avec vous un secours dicte le maquereau
le meilleur ami de le pen c'est clair et
le pen le meilleur allié de maquereaux
je suis d'accord aussi mais oui
honnêtement je suis je suis pas d'accord
avec vous quitte
vous parlez la crispation les terrains
de blocus parle pas ce n'est pas ça la
vie quotidienne des français et français
et continuent à se parler moi je suis
sûr qu'à 60 à 70% des français qui sont
au chaud qui partagent les mêmes idées
sur le fond je vais je crois que on
parle de dieu du reflet des choses on
parle de l'apparence des chances des
sondages qui ne reflète pas la réalité
de la france profonde et de la réalité
de la france
les gens ils continuent à se parler il
continue à penser la même chose souvent
sur nos routes m
par contre vous souviendrez problème à
mon avis un problème de l'élection
présidentielle vous dit que c'est un
moment de magie etc
mais beaucoup plus personne n'y croit ça
vous pensez que les gens sont naïfs à
skoura depuis le temps que le qui se
font avoir par l'élection présidentielle
on leur vend des tas de choses on leur
vend un nouveau monde une transformation
de leur français
mais les français finissent par ne plus
croire donc ils vont vous définissent
par s'abstenir ou alors ils voient sans
vraiment y croire
avec quel pourcentage des votants sur
macro a été je crois que c'est même pas
tout vous 13 % compte tenu de
l'agitation et marine le pen elle
faisait confiance pour cent de
l'électorat
donc je pense qu'il ya un vrai les
lâches partage un peu votre avis la
vraie et est clairement de l'opinion les
gens les réductions magie plus personne
n'y croit on arrive sur ce qu'elle tu as
quelqu'un de naïf mais c'est fini tout
ça et je pense que justement l'élection
présidentielle pour un vrai problème
c'est à dire que sur une élection
présidentielle reprenant sur un
personnage d'un personnage c'est très
fort
et puis une image de quelqu'un à travers
quelques à travers une image
télévisuelle à travers deux manières de
le maudire ou de le magnifier et on ne
discute plus
et justement moi je trouve que c'est
complètement aberrant d'avoir une
élection présidentielle qui dévorent les
autres élections notamment l'élection
législative alors que lors d'une
législative en principe on parle d'un
programme participe à des parties d'y
présenter un programme les législatives
on parle d'une personne l'époque pardon
les présidentielles on parle d'une
personne
je crois que la démocratie française en
train de crever à cause de sa cause de
l'élection présidentielle telle qu'elle
est vécue aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on
va des personnages aux français comme on
vend notamment lors des savonnettes et
du coup on ne parle plus du son des
problèmes est le problème le chemin
ensemble
la désindustrialisation la crise
sanitaire le lait les nier les faits
dans une victoire qui s'envole par le
puits aux élections parce que on parle
de personnages avant tous ces
personnages évidemment un programme et
higuain sont des gadgets on va supprimer
la taxe d'habitation va on va faire on
va créer on va recréer le service
militaire s'est toujours pas fait la
guerre au service national
donc ça se joue sur les gadgets ça ce
jour des images et non plus sur un vrai
débat de société
moi je regrette vraiment que cette
élection présidentielle était à tel
point dénaturer l'aspect part ça les
mordus de gaulle les élections
présidentielles je pense qu'elle a été
complètement dénaturé yacine il par la
démocratie française et moi ça
m'inquiète beaucoup
awad le nord je suis créé une grande
partie de ce qui vient d'être dit à
propos de l'élection présidentielle je
pense que beaucoup des difficultés ou
d'état pour être un peu plus durs de la
vie politique française viennent de là
ils compris la mli polarisation ou la
radicalisation de comparer puisque
l'élection présidentielle ce sol elle
parce qu'on tourne nécessairement par
construction un camp contre l'autre et
donc dans cette lutte d'un camp contre
l'autre il ya un camp qu'il doit battre
l'autre et ça je pense conduit
effectivement
a polarisé l'opinion est polarisé les
les candidatures et au delà je retire je
suis assez d'accord
tout ce qui a été dit sur cette pensée
mal cette pensée magique là je rappelle
que emmanuel macron a été élu avec un
programme qui parler de révolution
françois hollande de changements qui
devaient venir maintenant et même
nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs avait un
programme
un discours qui tu es sur la rupture et
qui rit tout ça rejoint d'ailleurs le
discours qu'on a aujourd'hui sur le
monde d'après après la caisse qui
devrait survenir après la crise des
espèces de pensée magique que la la
l'élection ou un mot où il y aurait on
sent qu'il ferait dans un monde où on
pourrait se saisir arrêter le temps s'en
saisir et transformer les transformer la
société
assez rapidement et en plus en général
sans faire de mal puisque il faut que
tout soit parfait
ces désillusions et tout ça tout ça non
seulement donc suscite d'abord de la
polarisation et ensuite nécessairement
une forte déception une certaine façon
est aujourd'hui victime et ce qui sera
intéressant c'est de voir comment marine
le pen va va reprendre ce sujet est-ce
que son sujet va être de dire elle est
que elle aussi est dans la rupture et
une fois qu'elle sera élue si elle l'est
ce sera une transformation soudaine de
la france des prennent et des pratiques
ou est ce que au contraire elle va
essayer de modérer ce discours là je
pense que les rapetou sur la première
option et que ça donne une voix aussi
pour les ponts ses adversaires pour
expliquer pourquoi eux s'ils sont élus
feront vraiment les transformations et
comment ils sont présents ici prendront
je pense que le discours de la méthode
de cette façon est un enjeu important
pour les adversaires de marine
alexis marine le pen en 2017
il y avait encore un politiquement
correct qui empêchait un certain nombre
d'électeurs de voter pour
pour marine le pen mais aujourd'hui sur
l'europe sur l'euro sur l'écologie elle
dit la même chose que les autres et et
sur l'islam sur l'immigration ce sont
les autres qui disent la même chose
qu'elle on se demande si aujourd'hui il
peut y avoir encore un principe moral ou
qui empêcherait de voter marine le pen
comme ça a été le cas depuis bien plus
longtemps que vous le disiez françois
bousquet parce que le front républicain
sa date des années 80 un pas de 2002
déjà dans les années 80 à droite comme à
gauche on invoquait le front républicain
pour se dresser contre eux jean marie à
l'époque où le front national
alors il nous reste juste deux minutes
avant la pause je vous donne la parole
françois bousquet on joue la rendra
ensuite au hainaut dire oui en effet que
j'ai raison ça remonte aux années 83 84
ans 84 que ça s'est mis en place ce
cordon sanitaire autour du front
national donc une prophylaxie qui
interdisait toute forme d'alliance salle
a été brisée à l'époque de maigret
ponctuellement mais mes sens ensuite est
ce que est ce que ce sera là en 2020 ce
que deux jeux sur suis pas sur moi je ce
que j'observe en tout cas j'aurais pas
dû front républicain on soit ils ont la
dimension anti fasciste le front anti
fascistes dans l'huile et antérieures et
remonte aux années 30
je suis plus sûr qu'ils soient
opératoire d'abord parce qu'il ya la
culture historique l'articulation c'est
n'est plus qualité
donc les référents les référents dans le
passé du xxème siècle s'éloigne
s'éloigne de nous et puis ensuite il ya
ce phénomène d'usure
on a six joue aussi souvent jouer cette
comédie la diabolisation
comment donner les plus gras toi même on
peut presque penser qu'elle produit des
effets inverses
en tout cas si on sentira trump
abandonner à trump dans les dames ans
est un cas spécifique c'est le cas
américain avec une crispation partisane
de parisot sont beaucoup plus violents
beaucoup plus marquée que kissick en
europe
pour autant c'est le trump pardon ne ne
s'est en aucun cas excuser d'être ce
qu'on lui reprochait d'être au contraire
ils l'assument et ça a séduit son
électorat je suis moins sûr que ce soit
aujourd'hui aussi efficace que ça peut
l'être par le passé on continue de
parler du front républicain puis du cas
de marine le pen en elle même parce
qu'elle revient de loin marine le pen un
croyait enterré en 2017
on revient juste après une pause
[Musique]
une crainte de l'inflation a poussé les
investisseurs à vendre des obligations
conséquence une forte remontée des taux
sur le marché c'est plutôt un
avertissement et et marché vis-à-vis de
la bande centrale de lui dire attention
même si l'économie repart
il n'est pas question que vous changiez
politique qu'il faudra pas que les
investisseurs jouent trop longtemps
parce que c'est une grosse main comme on
y est la réserve fédérale américaine
c'est celle qui dispose de la machine a
remis des billets de banque dans la cave
et qui a la capacité en fait de la faire
fonctionner sans aller en prison petto
ne peuvent pas donc on va forcer en fait
les banques centrales à continuer à
faire tourner la planche à billets comme
d'habitude cette thématique n existait
pas ya trois mois elle n'existera plus
dans trois mois
[Musique]
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'influencent a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée ce
cas la vérité finit toujours par éclater
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec à roanne le nom
avec maxime tandonnet et françois
bousquet françois gouws qui règne encore
une question vous êtes en tant que
rédacteur en chef du de la revue
éléments et fondateur de la nouvelle
librairie
c'est votre camp le camp de la droite
comment expliquez-vous le regain
d'intérêt aujourd'hui pour marine le pen
alors qu'en 2017 après le débat que vous
qualifiez vous même de calamiteuses tout
le monde la croyait enterrée y compris
dans son propre camp
comment expliquez vous son succès
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'incline pour dire que ben oui elle
pourrait gagner le défaut le défaut
d'alternative dans le corps à droite moi
est ce que marine le pen est de droite
vous remarquerez que ce clivage moi je
l'assumé ce qui marche de droite parce
qu'il ya une psychologie de droite ya
une métaphysique de droite mais en
termes électoraux ce clivage est de
moins en moins de moins en moins
efficace de macron de ce ni ni droite ni
gauche ou de droite et de gauche
marine le pen ne veut pas du tout
recourir à cette catégorisation du champ
politique
alain de benoist qui est victoria liste
de la région et des mandants la licra
lice appelle le mouvement populiste où
il dit que
ça une dimension le découpage politique
a une dimension perpendiculaire on avait
naguère quelque chose d'horizontal la
droite ou de latéral si vous préférez de
la droite vers la gauche et de la gauche
vers la droite
aujourd'hui le clivage est beaucoup plus
verticale
maxime tandonnet pas sursauter mais les
élites contre contre ce bloc contre ce
bloc populaire donc marine le pen
est-elle de droite j'en suis beaucoup
moins sûre en tout cas elle a deviné l'a
pressenti est électoralement ça pouvait
la desservir marion maréchal-le pen est
de droite
là il est clairement de droite de la
droite conservatrice et catholique
mais marine le pen n'ont donc alors pour
ensuite la résilience aller seul il ya
toutes les alternatives ont été essayées
jeu on à la candidature zemmour a été
éphémère elle a fait pschitt un mais
deux pendant trois mois elle a occupé
les journalistes on peut y aura d'autres
candidatures qui peut venir se glisser
entre macro et marine le pen mais elles
n'ont pas vocation à s'installer dans la
durée pour qu'elle est seule la
résilience de l'électorat et puis la
conviction peut-être vivant de la france
périphérique
moi j'ai pas été frappé pour moi il est
calamiteux le départ il est au delà des
calamiteuses débat c'est un comportement
des chèques qui était classique au sein
du front national du rnd rassemblement
national sert qu'on allait à l'élection
à reculons et le jour du débat elle fait
une migraine ophtalmique
en psychanalyse ça s'appelle un acte
manqué c'est à dire que vous oubliez de
réveil le jour de l'examen auquel savait
que cela n'allait pas réussir les cet
examen là donc elle fait migraine
terrible elle perd la vue en haut lieu
d'art ou de preuves est ce qu'elle veut
refaire ça en 2022 je ne crois pas je
crois que nous on a négligé le précédent
mitterrand le il faut regarder les
archives de l'ina mitterrand n'est pas
bon face à jusqu'à giscard le ballet
c'est une sorte de macron
embrun sexy et
on peut les techniciens en plus grand
plus logique que vous que peu importe
mais ils vraiment les himbas et 20
mitterrand et mitterrand sept ans plus
tard mais sept ans plus tard le
scintillant forts des leçons et de cette
expérience fort de ces erreurs ne
renouvelle pas il est l'homme du passif
et le lobe du passé démoli l'homme du
passif
il me semble en tout cas depuis deux
mois que marine le pen a fait des
efforts dont il n'avait jamais jusqu'à
la vo qu'elle n'avait jamais consenti
le débat sur bfm parvenait cité une
chaîne concurrente au moins masse m'a
surpris j'avais un autre personnage
serre que jusqu'à présent qu'en juillet
marine le pen foyer jean marie le pen je
parle en tant qu'électeur là c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui ce cuir assez il se
rengorger qui ricanaient qui était
franchement antipathique
là pour le coup elle devient sympathique
elle a tout légué milk du père ont
disparu alors certainement cas là des
communicants qui sont derrière et qui la
conseille donc ça va évidemment ça c'est
que de la comédie caustique mais il
n'empêche c'est un personnage beaucoup
plus agréable en tant qu'électeur du rnb
postulant que je sois un lecteur du rn
je rêverais plus envie de voter pour
elle aujourd'hui qu'en 2017
maxime tandonnet vous avez l'impression
qu'au contraire à une peine ça reste
marine le pen et que et que au fond
elle ne peut pas gagner pour cette même
raison non je ne dis pas qu'elle peut
pas gagner je dis je dis qu'on est en
démocratie qu'elle est candidate et qui
aime pas de raison qu'elle ait pas plus
qu elle escalade chance de gagner quel
très bien gagner et ça je jeûnais les
cartes je n'écarte pas du tout mais je
pense pas non plus qu'on puisse
raisonner en termes de son républicain
c'est vrai que c'est pas mon avis c'est
pas vraiment une affaire de l'alliance
républicaine contre contre contre marine
le pen
je crois qu'en terme de jeu crois qu'en
termes de sentiment j'imagine mal a
priori 50 plus de 50% des français de
voter pour elle parce que on a bien vu
des sondages effectivement qui la montre
dans le cosi post position assez
favorable aujourd'hui
mais qu'en sera-t-il quand il va falloir
on a engagé l'avenir du pays quand il va
falloir réfléchir dès des compétences
parce que c'est ça aussi on veut
quelqu'un qui a de l'expérience qui est
une compétence marine le pen en a pas le
losc est très important pour un
président de la république à mon avis
faisait tout à l'heure que ce n'était
pas ce n'est pas présenté le président
de la république comme comme une sorte
une sorte de malaise qui va régler d'un
coup de baguette magique tous les
problèmes si on français on leur vend
chaque fois il faut arrêter de leur
mentir à cet égard le président de la
république s'est pas idée il a pas une
baguette magique pour régler pour
transformer la france ni pour eux ni
pour un troll introduire dans un dans un
nouveau monde mais présent la république
qui doit être consensuelle et toi sa me
pouvoir rassembler une grande partie des
français derrière lui deux français sur
trois par forcément 10 votes pour lui
mais qui se reconnaissent en lui si vous
voulez et doit pouvoir inspirer la
confiance est présente
les doigts ont créé un consensus est de
créer une dynamique autour de 2 autour
de lui chirac a très bien su le faire ça
à une certaine époque
giscard d'estaing aussi d'ailleurs le
président de la république doit être
clivante parce que le présent il incarne
la nation et représente la nation à
l'extérieur et en coordination à
l'intérieur je pense que marine le pen
est fondamentalement même si elle a fait
des progrès même si elle a changé les
jeux je suis d'accord on a fait des
progrès je pense qu'elle représente
toujours un marine le pen marine le pen
des descendants de jean marie et jean ma
fille de jean marie le pen présidente du
rassemblement national
et si on ne veut pas je ne veux pas
faire de la diabolisation ça m'intéresse
pas je veux simplement dire que cette
position à les clientes et que c'est pas
des français n'ont pas besoin de
quelqu'un qui vivent à la tête de l'état
ils ont besoin de quelqu'un qui puisse
rassembler qu'ils puissent être
consensuel qui puisse inspirer la
confiance est elle même la sympathie du
grand une grande partie des compatriotes
dire deux français sur trois comme des
avis car destin rainbow mais maquereau a
eu sa au moment de son élection et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ça ça font très
vite
c'est aujourd'hui le vote d'adhésion
il est il est très limité et et en
nombre et dans le temps par rapport à
une autre génération qu'on a pu
connaître
erwan maintenant oui alors emmanuel
macron performance assez extraordinaire
en 2007 cela étant il faut se rappeler
que son score au sort du premier tour et
pas inclus est extraordinairement élevé
il est plus faible et ce qui lui promet
d'aller dans les sondages pour 2022
mais c'est pas on n'est pas au score 2
28 % comme la aujourd'hui marine le pen
comme l'ont eu par le passé des
candidats qui leur donne interne une
assise très forte donc emmanuel macron
lahoud est cette performance il a quand
même commencé son mandat et une assise
électorale relativement faible qui qui
compromettait les réformes pour
peut-être les plus audacieuses et c'est
fait c'est très facile d'avoir enfin un
cas a commenté de mon point de vue a
posteriori probablement et est plus
difficile sur le moment mais en ayant à
peu près d'un quart de l'électorat à
peine sur votre route sur votre
candidature vous pouvez vous avez donc
comme le disait maxime tandonnet vous
n'avez pas les 70% de français sur trois
arrêts vous ils sont contre vous entrez
ils sont pas déplacés sont vous avez pas
susciter leur enthousiasme leur adhésion
des lieux au moment où on leur a demandé
de voter
aucun mal à vous partez avec la capitale
faible et donc les erreurs ou les
réformes qui sont trop clivante
nécessairement continue d'amenuiser ce
capital et c'est au delà de ce qu'on
disait à l'instant peut-être de l'image
de marine le pen il ya un autre
paramètre qui est à prendre en compte
qui rejoint 7,7 s'est effritement et du
président mc ren c'est c'est
l'abstention et c'est la pauvreté des
autres offres politiques je pense que la
plus grande chance de marine le pen
vient de des défauts voire de la
relative
de la médiocrité relative des offres
alternatives mais on n'a pas aujourd'hui
lr et les mêmes et les rues m où les
différents candidats de gauche sont pas
un projet qui soit claire qu'elle soit
qu'ils soient qui soit susceptible de
constituer une offre une offre
attractive moi je suis libéral exploit
c'est l'offre qui crée la demande
quand vous avez pas d'or où est la
demande elle et elle est perdue et elle
se tourner vers l'offre qui peut sembler
la plus la plus constituer la plus
attractive la plus innovante et puis
elle se détourne simplement est donc là
là l'une des chances de marine le pen
c'est cette combinaison d'offre
alternative peu séduisante et
d'abstention
la raison pour laquelle marine le pen
monte dans les sondages
on va dire ça quand même que emmanuel
macron baisse dans ces mêmes sondages si
elle arrive aujourd'hui à 40%
c'est parce que lui même a baissé à 52 %
hors et emmanuel macron vous disiez
maxime tandonnet on veut des gens
compétents et caetera et c'est
certainement au moment du débat en 2017
c'était criant pour peut-être pour les
raisons qui expliquaient françois
bousquet que emmanuel macron avait l'air
plus compétents que marine le pen
mais quand on va être l'année prochaine
on sera après quasiment deux ans de
qu'ovide citant tech on n'a pas vaincu
d'épidémie d'ici là est-ce que emmanuel
macron va paraître aussi compétent qu'il
le semblait en 2017
la crise du coc vide c'est terrible pour
tous ceux qui auront été au pouvoir
pendant le coc vide
non c'est moi qui vous ai fait pendant
en 2022 il est sûr que les jeux de rôle
sera complètement complètement différent
max ne pourra pas jouer si le s'il est
candidat s'il est 2e tour j'en sais rien
moi je dis je suis complètement moi j'ai
aucun pronostic est cet égard s'il est
au deuxième tour il pourra pas refaire
le même
même communication sur sa compétence et
est ce possible je ne jouera évidemment
de peu pareil
mais on peut se demander d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui pourrait promettre qu'elle
rock'n'roll il pourra jouer il pourra
jouer dans ce cas mais je crois que
justement après deux tours le contexte
de dramatique la france aura vécu
pendant pendant deux ans avec les plus
de cent mille morts sans doute avec une
crise économique effroyable à mon avis
la tendance sera plutôt de ce rien de
s'orienter vers vers l'expérience pas
vers quelqu'un qui n'aura jamais eu la
moindre expérience de l'état pas
quelqu'un qui apparaîtra comme
totalement totalement nouveau sur la
scène politique je ne sais pas trop je
pense que c'est plutôt expériences et
des gens qui ont fait leurs preuves
qu'ils pourront qui pourront offrir une
chance de se distinguer dans cette
élection je sais de réfléchir en termes
de psychologie du peuple allemand après
une crise pareille qu'est ce qu'on
cherche cherche quelqu'un qui a
l'expérience on cherche quelqu'un qui
rassure qui respire la confiance donc
j'ai pas de nom à mettre derrière ça
malheureusement je pense que ce sera
plutôt la tendance et qui prévaudra le
bug françois bousquet oui c'est pas le
procès en incompétence de marine le pen
et anciens il s'est déjà adressé ce
procès en incompétence au père il est
globalement adressé au rassemblement
national peut-être qu'il y aura du
changement
à cet égard là je voudrais revenir sur
cette notion de deux français sur trois
c'est une séquence qui est très loin
derrière nos deux français sur trois
c'est l'époque de la moyennisation de
l'avènement de les classes moyennes de
l'épanouissement de la société de
consommation et ont commencé à basculer
des trente glorieuses vers les trente
piteuses
ce que j'observe m'a au contraire c'est
une société qui est très frais facturés
les actes des gilets jaunes ont montré
les livres de guides lui de montres en
attestent et comment ne serait-elle pas
fracturée il ya un décrochage de plus en
plus massif de cette phase moyenne est
en train de se paupériser de se
déclasser
donc il ya des catégories populaires ou
des classes moyennes inférieures qui ne
se retrouve pas du tout dans cette
société consensuelle la société
aujourd'hui est plutôt dit sensuelle
entre une élite parisienne le culturel
institutionnel qui contrôle les médias
sont trop pour ne pas parler de rtx
clarté est un cas à part
en tout cas les médias centraux qui
contrôlent l'institution judiciaire
ils contrôlent l'institution
universitaire qui a une rom de monopole
en fait sur l'ensemble dès leviers de
pouvoir et une france périphérique
complètement déclassé en colère je te
manges observe au contraire une très
grande colère le seul philosophe qui a
défendu la colère comme vertu politique
c'est aristote pour peu que cette colère
réparer une injustice et beaucoup de
français ont le sentiment dans cette
france des marges ont cette diagonale du
vide que celle gens ont le sentiment
d'avoir été totalement abandonnée donc
la colère est toute puissante
inutile d'insister sur les gilet jaune
le mouvement des filets jaunes a été
fascinant on n'avait plus vu ça depuis
plus d'un an une protestation fiscal
devient virale déjà contagieuse
évidemment elle est éphémère par
définition puisque c'est viral ça
retombe
mais on n'avait jamais vu ça et le
slogan qui résume le mieux me
semble-t-il cjd jaune
le choeur électorale du front national
et de marine le pen s'est baissé des
prix certains mais c'est aussi le mépris
dont jeu il me semble qu on en est très
loin je crois qu'au contraire les deux
candidats de se se recentrent sur leur
socle idéologique leur socle
sociologique
qu'est ce qu'a fait macron macron il a
fait la synthèse de la bourgeoisie de
gauche la bourgeoisie droite c'est assez
important
s'imaginer que dans la france
périphérique on l a pas conscience non
des ressorts de classe que perdure c'est
pas le seul ressort du rn à leurs salles
de classe et un resort identitaire il
ressort migratoires qui joue et où est
ce que ca observent dans la france
périphérique c'est que les catégories
populaires qui votent marine le pen
appelle délibérément pour donner un
exemple concret leurs enfants et des
prêts d'anglo saxons pas parce qu'ils
sont complètement contaminés par les
séries télévisées il
son mais pas que ça c'est aussi pour se
démarquer de la banque des prénoms et
gothique le snob des élites
métropolitaine donc vraiment les cambrai
me semble à l'état de cristal on en est
loin de là bien sûr mais semble me
semble se resserrer sur leurs noyaux et
je reviens sur un dernier point sur
je crois qu on se méprend si l'on
considère que la présidentielle dans un
schéma populiste en plus mais la
présidentielle et populiste par nature
populiste puisqu'elle met en vis-à-vis
deux personnalités elle repose sur une
personnalisation outrancière
si on s'imagine que l'élection
présidentielle se joue sur des ressorts
rationnel on en est très loin les
français quand ils votent ils cochent
pas plus moi la case macro et la creuse
marine le pen je redis c'est une
opération très brève des clauses de la
raison
j'ai une éclipse de la raison pendant 2
3 mois qui permet à tous les espoirs
évidemment ça retombe mais ça ça 7,40
riez rythment la vie électorale rythme
l'arrivée politique française sinon on
décrocherait envahirait aux corneilles
depuis très longtemps si on devait
parler que d'eux que de choses
rationnelles rappelez-vous le mot de
pascal le locker a des raisons que la
raison ignore
on excède très largement cette dimension
rationnelle on fait pas un calcul
utilitaire quand on veut tant on cherche
pas à maximiser son profit ou à
minimiser ses pertes 1 on fait bien
autre chose donc on n'est pas dans cette
séquence j'en conviens comme vous
l'imprudent ciel intéresse qu aux
journalistes raison pour laquelle nous
sommes tous là et nous sommes tous peu
ou prou des journalistes mais le moment
venu quand les français entreront en
scène c'est à dire trois mois avant
l'échéance la rassurez vous je ça va
être une dramaturgie une dramatique
comme on disait à l'époque de france
télévisions le france 2 pardon qui ce
qui va fonctionner erwan le nom quelle
influence pensez vous que va voir
la crise du coc vide en général sur
cette prochaine élection c'est dans un
an quoi l'élection présidentielle est là
et l'année qui vient risque d'être
particulièrement tendu en europe et
d'ailleurs pour l'europe aussi vous avez
dit que vous étiez libéral j'imagine que
vous êtes aussi pro européen
beaucoup de projets européens
aujourd'hui s'inquiètent ils
s'inquiètent de l'image que le peu de
données l'europe aujourd'hui dans cette
crise du comider notamment dans la
campagne de vaccination qui est a priori
jusqu'à présent un échec ça a forcément
avoir de l' influence tout à fait je
pense ça va effectivement avoir une
influence déterminante sur le sur la
perception l'union européenne sait c'est
catastrophique la gestion de la campagne
de vaccination par l'europe
et comme vous l'avez dit un échec est
d'autant plus un échec on voit que des
pays qui nous sont proches et qui ont
une autre gestion réussissent très bien
en grande bretagne qui vient de s'en
sauver l'union européenne alors c'est
bien convaincu que ce soit lié mais il
ya effectivement ça a permis d'acquérir
une plus grande liberté dans sa gestion
de la crise et aujourd'hui il est
cartonne dans les sondages
un autre pays qui nous est proche
également extrait on voit rouvre
aujourd'hui lorsqu'ils ont une très
bonne gestion de la crise il est la
campagne de vaccination et ça évidemment
ceux venus des contrées d'entrée
immédiat très proche de ce qui aurait pu
être fait alors c'est toujours facile à
posteriori mais sur le coup et
effectivement c'est très mauvais pour la
percée de perception de l'europe et je
crois que ce qui est très mauvais et
également pour l'image que l'europe
donne d'elle-même c'est de refuser
d'admettre qu'elle a pu se tromper quand
on entend ce qui est dit sur les
critiques sont portées très vertement
sur israël et la grande bretagne
probablement de ces pays sont pas
parfaits mais je pense que là la
fragilité l'union européenne il ya
d'abord de notre
nous nous reposerons et l'admettre
serait déjà je pense renforcé en france
et l'europe sur les consoles aux
conséquences qu'auront que pourront que
pourra avoir la crise sanitaire elles
vont être énormes d'avoir pour cette
raison d'avoir les comparaisons entre
les pays qui ont su gérer et second pas
su le faire et ensuite parce que on est
entre aujourd'hui et ont non seulement
dans une crise économique qui va être
intense qui va avoir des conséquences
sociales inévitables l'état aujourd'hui
a ouvert les vannes de l'argent public
pour soutenir les salariés les
entreprises qui en ont besoin
ça pourra pas durer il ya des donc la
conséquence sociale progressé mais
progressivement se faire toujours se
faire plus forte
fort probablement et qui dit conséquent
sociale dit à terme également
conséquences politiques parce qu'il va y
avoir de la colère qui va croire des
l'angoissent qui va accroître parce
qu'il va y avoir aussi des questions
politiques qui vont se poser sur les
inégalités on voit que c'est des
questions qui commencent à monter qu'ils
sont qui porte à 1 nice aura un terreau
fertile pour pour des thèmes populistes
des thèmes des thèmes de colère donc il
est évident que cette crise n'a pas fini
d'avoir un nom n'a pas fini d'avoir
toutes les répercussions politiques
françois bousquet l'afld lors du comice
je me souviens d'avoir trouvé marine le
pen il ya une dizaine d'années à peu
près je vais demander mathématiquement à
ce moment là elle n'avait aucune chance
d'arriver au pouvoir il va dit qu'est ce
qu'il ferait à votre avis que vous
puissiez tout à coup gagné plusieurs
aspects là et je sais pas elle devait
avoir fait on était après les élections
de 2
ils 12
oui c'est ça c'était après 2012 et
élections où elle avait fait moins que
son père et bruno mégret en 2002 donc ce
n'était pas du tout la réussite qu'on
disait à l'époque au contraire et génie
pour inverser la tendance et el bahi
ferait une énorme crise une grande
grande crise quelque chose ou tout à
coup les français soient stupéfait par
l'ampleur de la crise et je crois qu'on
y est là la crise ou que vides
elle a surpris tous bondés et tout le
monde est encore stupéfait est ce qu'à
votre avis françois bousquet ça peut
être la crise alors qu'ils imaginaient
marine le pen mais surtout là là quelle
influence peut qu est-ce que ça peut
avoir sur la prochaine présidentielle de
de crise écoutez en 2017 on aurait pu
dire en tout cas en terme
de terrorisme ce que tu avais une
situation assez exceptionnelle il y
avait plus de 200 morts il n'y a pas eu
il ya pas eu de traduction électorale
deux de ces attentats en série
aujourd'hui macron à une cote de
confiance eux est étonnamment haute en
tout cas eu égard aux précédents je
crois pas de françois hollande françois
hollande était vraiment au fond du trou
il était en train de se noyer après le
pédalo en train de se noyer
mais sarkozy n'avait pas la cote de
confiance que combattre on peut se
prévaloir jusqu'à présent le les
confinements larvée d'aidé confinement
in a interrompu servent servent en
partie macro
il n'y a pas de mouvements gilet jaune
les crises sociales sont repoussées pour
le troisième tour social est repoussé en
quelque sorte une fois de plus est ce
que ça va durer six heures confinement
bon on peut imaginer avec un confinement
[Musique]
macron va plonger dans dans les sondages
alors la crise on attend d'en voir les
effets est-ce qu'elle va jouer pour
marine le pen oui c'est possible puisque
le tonnerre je parlais d'un procès en
incompétence et que font les français
depuis même en maintenant une certaine
confiance un maquereau depuis un an
depuis qu'on est rentré dans le premier
confinement il ya un an c'est un procès
en incompétence à nos zélites techno à
l'aller large le procès en incompétence
c'est là un procès au laboratoire aux
politiques tous les grands corps d'état
tard que le principe de peter
qui veut que en atteint d'un stade
d'incompétence et bien il semblerait
pour l'esprit des français moi si je
m'en tiens aux sondages à la perception
dont la crise est gérée bas que
manqueront à arte son seuil de
compétence ou d'incompétence en passant
de mains du ministère des finances à
l'elysée or peut-être qu'il y aurait une
traduction électorale bat 6 pour le
front national leur enfant de rationnel
plutôt souhaitons deuil il faut attendre
des effets de la crise tant qu'on sera
confiné ton qu'on vivra sous cloche
le tout cette colère souterraine ne
pourra pas surgir mais dès qu on sunday
qu'on lèvera la cloche en dés qu'on
lèvera le sous vide et qu'on reviendra
dès qu'on passera de 8 vivent au sein
des laboratoires wind d'une vie trop de
laboratoire ou une vive au pardon
peut-être alors là
les colères vont exploser et se venger
contre contre les sortants pour sortir
les sortants dernier mot maxime
tandonnet sur le sujet jouer dans les
deux sens en fait la crise covin peut
jouer dans les deux sens on peut voir
l'élection présidentielle comme le
disait très bien monsieur bousquet une
éclipse de lune éclipses de la raison
c'est un terme très fort c'est à dire
que l'on fait n'importe quoi en fait un
vol sur la côte uniquement en fonction
de sa colère de ces patients sont les
toits c'est possible que ça joue comme
ça moi je suis pas certain parce que
j'adore les français
moi j'ai plutôt confiance dans la raison
des gens justement je crois pas les
clips de la raison je pense que j'espère
que la raison va prévaloir justement et
mais je pense que les français
choisiront plutôt dans une situation
aussi dramatique et autant de morts
autant de drames se diront pas forcément
de même à venir les équipes en place
mais ils choisiront qu'ils choisiront
des candidats et candidats qui a fait
pas forcément je suis par le conseil
pour la compétence je suis pas capable
de dire ça mais d'expérience qu'elle a
l'expérience de l'état qui a
l'expérience des crises qu'a déjà vécu
ce genre de situation et a mon avis
c'est le plus tôt dans ce sens soit pour
jouer mais je n'en suis pas sûr du tout
non sincèrement non dernière question
on a beaucoup parlé d'eux des électeurs
de gauche qui ne veulent plus voter en
tout cas une partie d'entre eux qui ne
voudraient plus voter pour marc webb
pour emmanuel macron qui ne se
déplaceront pas vous y croyez alors on
est à un an de l'élection mais
il ya du temps d'ici là mais vous n'y
croyez vous que vous croyez que c'est
possible oui je pense je pense que c'est
probablement pas une majorité
d'électeurs de gauche vous voyez au
moment de choisir une partie qui pourra
pas se résoudre à l'élection de
l'extrême droite fort heureusement mais
c'est une tendance qui est de plus en
plus forte et qu' un certain nombre
d'électeurs qui qui ne croient plus en
la politique l'expression est très
galvaudé mais qui qui ne ne sont plus
prêts à se déplacer pour mettre un
bulletin pour un candidat qu'ils
n'attendent pas grand-chose et peuvent
être dans une logique un peu de la
politique du pire donc oui je pense que
ces relations relativement vrai
avec en plus pour certains probablement
l'idée que
c'est en en coulant matheron qui serait
ouvriront une opportunité électorale de
façon très cynique beaucoup c'est une
eau pure hypothèse à laquelle je crois
je vous remercie tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]